hi lan hi martin
what are we building today so i need to
automate some admin tasks in looker what
is google cloud's business intelligence
and big data analytics platform i've
heard that it can be done with cloud
functions
that's right
but i have to warn you i don't know
looker at all no worries if you bring
your cloud function know-how i will
bring my local skills
sounds good let's do it
[Music]
so i often need to register local user
accounts for my co-workers but sometimes
i forget and people get annoyed so i
would like to automate that process
okay got it
so my users usually fill out a google
form so their email addresses end up in
a google spreadsheet can we build a
cloud function so that it reads that
spreadsheet nicely and then create local
user accounts for my co-workers
yes we can
this is actually a pretty common use
case for cloud functions run on a
schedule read a sheet or some other data
source and take actions based on that
data
sounds like cloud functions is a glue
code in the cloud
yes that's a good uh
good way of putting it cloud functions
are great for gluing together other
systems so i looked at cloud function
documentation and i saw that we can
write the functions in python
yes we can google cloud functions also
support node go
java.net ruby and php good i know python
pretty well but how do you read google
sheet in python
here is an example first it gets the
default credentials then it creates a
service object then a sheet api client
and we can call values.get on that sheet
api client and pass in the sheet id and
range of cells to read
but now it's my turn to ask you a
question how do you create looker
accounts from python it's pretty simple
actually so we need to import the lookup
sdk like this we create an sdk object
and then we can call methods on it like
the right user to create a new user
account
all right
so i will go to my project in google
cloud console
and here i'll select cloud functions
i'll wait for it to be enabled
and then i click here to create a new
function
i give the new function a good name
and i'll make sure that require
authentication has been selected so that
it can't be triggered by just anyone out
there on the internet
and when i click next here the code
editor opens up
good
so we can wrap these code fragments in
python functions
then we just need to tell google which
of these functions is the entry point
that entry point should take a flask
request object as its only input
parameter
i think between the two of us we know
enough to write this code
let's do it
first i'll write the imports
and the first two will be needed to read
the google sheet and the next two import
the looker sdk
then i will write the function that is
the entry point it calls a function that
reads the email addresses from a google
sheet looks over these emails calls a
function that creates a local user
account for each of these email
very good then i will write the function
here that reads email addresses from the
sheet it will create a sheet client and
call values.get on it and read all the
values from the b column
i will open our google sheet also and
copy the sheet id from that address and
paste it into the sheet id variable in
our code
then i will write the function that
creates user's account in looker first
it calls create user on the local client
then it calls create user credentials
email to set up new email for these
users credentials
excellent
and
also put in our requirements.txt file
all right but lan how does looker know
who we are and what looker project we're
adding users to
so luka will read the base url the
client id and a secret from an ini file
ah got it
okay so we put it in there
and i'll deploy the function by clicking
this button
let's test the function i'll click here
to call it
oh
that doesn't look good
let's check the log
something about permissions
we never granted access to the
spreadsheet did we if i click details it
looks like the functions is running as
his account so i copy that
i go to the spreadsheet
i click share then i grant the viewer
access to the spreadsheet
click that test button again
alright here it goes
oh looks like it works uh and the log oh
yeah the log says here that the accounts
were created
but martin there's one part you have
forgotten about
uh didn't we do it all
no we have not scheduled to run nightly
oh you're right
let's do that in cloud scheduler
first i'll copy the url that triggers
this function
then i'll go to cloud scheduler and
click this button to schedule a job
i give a little name here
i'll enter 0 0 star star star which
means every night at midnight in the
unix cron
format then i'll set it to your time
zone lan japan standard time
i will set the target type to http and
paste in the url for our cloud function
and because the function isn't public i
will need to set off header to oidc
token
i'll pick the default compute account
for now but if we take this to
production we should consider creating a
custom service account that has access
to trigger cloud functions and nothing
more
yeah that's the principle of the least
privilege i like that
yes exactly let's test it right now so
we don't have to wait until tomorrow to
see if it works
ah good idea
let's click this run button and give it
a minute
okay i'll click view logs
looks like it ran
and if i remove all these filters here
we see the logs from our cloud function
too
great it's working
now i can just tell my users to submit
their email addresses in my form and
local accounts will be great for them at
midnight
very good
thank you everyone for watching if you
have questions for lan or me about this
episode or feedback or ideas for future
episodes please enter them in the
comments below bye
[Music]
you